Speaker 1: All right, let's continue
today. I'm not even going to waste time
telling you how important it is to become a
member. Join Pakman because we just have to
too much going on. And it wouldn't be respectful
to people to derail the show with such irrelevant,
innocuous announcements. So we won't do
that. A little more vaccine discussion.
This is also just a very interesting exchange and
I don't exactly know the full way I would describe
it. But over the last 24 to 36 hours, there's just
been a little bit of a different dynamic about the
tone of how a lot of this vaccination problem that
the United States has is being discussed. I think
most of it is pretty productive. Here's an
example that is not very productive. White House
Press Secretary Jen Psaki yesterday held a press
briefing. And during this press briefing, she was
initially asked by FOX reporter Peter Doocy and
then another reporter sort of followed up about
it. And the gist of the question was, shouldn't
Joe Biden go and ask Donald Trump for help
so that Trump will come out and tell his followers
that they should go and get vaccinated. And,
of course, if you watched yesterday's program, you
might be thinking, wait, Trump just basically put
out an anti vaccine statement. Now, you want
Trump to go and ask people to get vaccinated.
And the truth is, Trump may actually do it
because everything Trump is doing is merely
merely to hurt Joe Biden. And if the imagery
suited Trump of Biden going to him and saying,
Mr. Former President, I need your help, I need you
to put out a statement so that your followers will
get vaccinated, Trump would probably do it.
He would drop the anti back stuff right away
as long as he gets credit for it. So let's jump
into this year's Peter Doocy asking Jen Psaki,
maybe Joe Biden should be reaching out
to Donald Trump. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 3: I'm vaccine hesitancy as
Speaker 1: covid-19, by the way. No one
can silence their phones in this room.
You've got to be kidding me. This is
Speaker 3: rise. If this is becoming a
pandemic of the unvaccinated and you guys
are having a hard time getting a certain
part of the population to go get the shot.
Speaker 1: Right now, what he doesn't say
is part of the reason you're having trouble
is because of Trump and other Republicans telling
people this administration is not trustworthy.
That's part of why you're having trouble. He
doesn't mention you're sort of having trouble
because of Trump president.
Speaker 3: I never called
former President Trump and say, I need your
help. Let's cut a PSA and tell people to go.
Speaker 1: Trump would love that, wouldn't he?
Speaker 4: Well, first, I would say that what
we've seen and our data is that the most trusted
voices are local officials, doctors, medical
experts, civic leaders, clergy from time to time.
Speaker 1: This is really important because
when you ask people who do you trust
the most on these types of things,
people aren't saying any elected official. Now,
there are some hard core trumpet's who are just
listening to Trump. So that's absolutely a fact.
Speaker 4: And that is where we have really
invested our funding and our resources. We've
seen almost every former president play a role
in putting out a PSA, making sure people
understood in the country that the vaccine
is safe and effective. We don't believe that
requires an embroidered invitation to be a
part of it, but certainly any role of anyone who
has a platform where they can provide information
to the public that the vaccine is safe, it is
effective. We don't see this as a political
issue. We'd certainly welcome that engagement.
Speaker 1: Right now, the thing is, because of
Trump's narcissism, he has to be invited.
That's the thing. Trump wants Biden to come
begging. And of course, Donald Trump is
the one reinforcing the talking point
that people aren't getting vaccinated because
they don't trust the Biden administration. We
looked at that statement yesterday and I'll put
part of it up on the screen. Trump said Joe Biden
kept talking about how good of a job he's doing on
the distribution of the vaccine that was developed
by Operation Warp Speed or quite simply, the
Trump administration. He's not doing well at all.
He's way behind schedule, a far more aggressive
schedule than Trump ever put together.
And people are refusing to take the vaccine
because they don't trust his administration. So,
first of all, Trump's reinforcing the talking
point that is preventing some people from going
and getting vaccinated and saying, you really
can't trust Biden, it's socialist, it's communist,
and people don't trust the administration.
Second, again, Biden doesn't have to ask Trump,
Obama, Bush and Clinton did it on their
own. Why does Donald Trump have to be
asked by Joe Biden to do this? And the answer is
because he's a narcissist and now he's holding
this over Joe Biden's head or attempting to and
working against Joe Biden up until such time,
until Joe Biden comes and says pretty. Please,
sir, will you go and do a video? And the
most remarkable thing about this is Trump doesn't
care about his followers. Understand that if it's
useful for Trump politically as he perceives
it, to encourage people not to get the vaccine,
he'll do the sort of anti vaccine. You can't
really trust this administration talking points.
If it makes Trump look good to have Biden
come groveling to him, please do a video so
your people will get vaccinated. Then Trump
will do it. One outcome leads to death. One
outcome leads to vaccination and mostly not death.
Trump doesn't care, he's indifferent between the
two. It's whatever makes him look politically
the strongest. That's all the guy cares about.
Now, here's where it got a little weird. The
next reporter also followed up. Why isn't the
Biden administration doing enough here when it
comes to giving Trump credit for the vaccines?
Speaker 3: They should have a follow up to
a question about sure vaccine. OK, question
and my follow up. Even if the administration
doesn't partner with the former president,
would you consider highlighting or acknowledging
in a greater way his role in creating the vaccines
to assure the rural voters who
still support President Trump
but are hesitant to get the vaccine?
Speaker 4: Well, I think do you have
data to suggest that that's the issue that's
preventing people from getting vaccinated?
Speaker 1: So that's a great question.
On the one hand, I've said before,
maybe you got a call. This thing trump
juice and market it like a popular
soda to these people. Maybe that'll make
them get vaccinated. On the other hand,
do we have reason to believe that they're waiting
for Trump to say something? Because increasingly
it seems they want to hear from local doctors and
their local clergy for those that are religious,
Speaker 3: what we're seeing that the communities,
the communities that have the lowest vaccination
rates did seem to vote for President
Speaker 4: Trump. OK, but what I'm
asking you is if information related to
whether or not the former president got
credit is leading people not to get vaccinated.
Right. Or is it information like microchips in
vaccines and it causing fertility issues, causing
health issues? Because you're drawing a few
conclusions there that I haven't seen and data,
but maybe you have that information to provide.
Speaker 3: No, but I think it's just it's I think
it's an issue. I mean, I think it's a common sense
that these are people who supported him. These are
people who are hesitant to get vaccinated. I don't
think it takes a lot to draw the conclusion.
Speaker 4: Well, let me be very clear. Our
our objective is to ensure all Americans will get
vaccinated. That would be of course, we would love
that. Democrats, Republicans, independents. It's
not a political issue to us. The virus does not
sorry. The virus does not look at people's
party affiliation. We recognize that the
president's going to govern for all people.
What I'm conveying to you is you're jumping
to a few conclusions that I don't think data
backs up in terms of what the impacts are.
Speaker 1: I think that they both are
making good points here in the sense that
it's very clear that if Donald Trump just focused
on saying people go and get vaccinated, listen,
it's my vaccine after all, give me the glory
by going and taking the Trump vaccine, it would
have an impact. At the same time, the data doesn't
suggest that it's what elected officials say that
is having the greatest impact on whether they are
or aren't going to get vaccinated. They say it's
local doctors and clergy. We know, unfortunately,
that while they may not be admitting it,
disinformation that they're seeing on social media
seems to also be playing a significant role. So I
can see both sides of that. But if the point is
Trump wants Biden to come begging him to help,
that's just more about Trump's
narcissism than anything else.